your surgeon will perform bariatric
surgery if your weight loss efforts
through lifestyle changes and
medications have been unsuccessful there
are two types of bariatric surgery
restrictive procedures decrease the size
of the stomach so a person feels full
quickly after surgery the stomach holds
about one cup of food a normal stomach
holds four to six cups malabsorptive
procedures decrease the absorption of
calories in the small intestine
before your procedure an intravenous
line will be started bariatric surgery
requires general anesthesia which puts
you to sleep for the duration of the
procedure
a breathing tube will be inserted
through your mouth and into your
windpipe to help you breathe during the
operation
gastric bypass technically referred to
as roux and why gastric bypass is both a
restrictive and malabsorptive procedure
because it reduces the size of the
stomach and decreases the absorption of
calories in the small intestine
your surgeon will use one of two methods
for gastric bypass surgery the open
method requires an 8 to 10 inch incision
in the abdomen the laparoscopic method
only requires several small keyhole
incisions through which your surgeon
will pass a laparoscope and surgical
tools a laparoscope is a thin lighted
instrument that projects images of the
surgery on a monitor in the operating
room
during a ruin why gastric bypass
procedure your surgeon will use surgical
staples to create a small compartment
which will serve as your new stomach
this pouch will hold about one cup of
food the lower portion of the stomach
continues to secret digestive juices but
does not receive food next your surgeon
will cut the small intestine well beyond
the stomach and bring one free end up
and attach it to the pouch he or she
will then attach the other free end
lower down on the small intestine
creating a wide shape by bypassing the
lower stomach and the first part of the
small intestine fewer calories will be
absorbed as food passes through this new
pathway banding techniques are
restrictive procedures they help
decrease food intake in two ways by
shrinking the stomach to a small pouch
and by making a tiny opening from the
pouch to the rest of the stomach food
moves slowly through this opening these
factors make you feel full quicker and
for a longer time
in vertical banded gastroplasty also
known as vbg or stomach stapling your
surgeon will cut a window in the upper
part of your stomach he or she will play
staples in your stomach around the
window and toward the esophagus to
create a small pouch on top next your
surgeon will pass a rigid plastic band
through the window and wrap it around
the small outlet of the pouch which will
prevent stretching food will move from
this pouch through a tiny opening into
the lower stomach and the rest of the
digestive tract
during an adjustable gastric banding
procedure also known as a GB or lap band
your surgeon will wrap an inflatable
ring around the upper part of the
stomach as the band is inflated it will
squeeze the stomach to create a small
upper pouch and a narrow opening into
the larger lower portion this may be
done through tiny incisions using a
laparoscope the band may be adjusted at
any time
billy-oh pancreatic diversion is a
malabsorptive procedure that decreases
the amount of calories absorbed in your
small intestine your surgeon will begin
by removing part of the stomach leaving
only a small pouch behind next he or she
will sew the small intestine to the
pouch this creates a direct route from
the pouch to the end of the small
intestine the duodenum and jejunum are
bypassed so few calories and nutrients
are absorbed
for all methods of bariatric surgery
your surgeon will close your incisions
with staples or stitches after your
procedure your breathing tube will be
removed and you will be taken to the
recovery area for monitoring you will be
given pain medication and your diet will
be gradually advanced over several days